bonjour benoît muracciole merci d'être
avec nous aujourd'hui sur rt france
alors quelles raisons ont poussé les
deux puissances justement à ne plus
vouloir vendre d'armes à l'arabie
saoudite et aux émirats arabes unis
il ya toujours plusieurs facteurs dans
décisions qui sont prises mais pour
l'italie il y avait une mobilisation
extrêmement importante de des rites et
des jarres moquette une organisation qui
regroupe plusieurs ong en italie et des
églises italiennes
ça c'est un des éléments extrêmement
fort aux etats unis les églises aussi
ont dû se mobiliser mais on a vu les
parlementaires c'est à dire à la fois le
la chambre de représentants et le sénat
même sous l'ère trump voté par trois
fois l'arrêt de ce soutien militaire
coffre coffret les états unis à la
coalition arabie séoudite émirats arabes
unis et elles vont être les conséquences
directes justement de ce retrait
américain et italien dans le conflit le
premièrement ce qui était alors rien
l'australie aussi qui s'est jointe à
cette suspension
donc que nous avons l'allemagne même
s'il raille métal continue à travers
l'afrique du sud notamment où là la
sardaigne donc l'italie continuer
d'envoyer des armes en arabie saoudite
il ya quelques gars y'a une onde de choc
extrêmement importante c'est à dire que
tous ses états le font parce qu'ils
savent qu'il y à des crimes de guerre
nous venons de sortir un rapport qui est
d'ailleurs disponible sur notre site
internet
azerty ray asso.org qui dit que ce sont
des crimes contre l'humanité donc
maintenant toutes les capitales du monde
le singe la question c'est juste une
question de complicité
dia dans de nombreux pays la question
des droits de l'homme qui est quand même
centrale
en france elle ne l'est plus ça c'est
extrêmement grain et mais ça va être de
plus en plus difficile notamment 1
la grande-bretagne pour la grande
bretagne et la france de continuer à
suppléer ces deux pays au moins ces deux
pays dans la dans le conflit au yémen
je crois quand même que pour le peuple
yéménite
ce n'est pas bien sûr immédiat un des
intervenants que vous avez vous avez
fait entendre disait fort justement que
malheureusement il y a encore beaucoup
de munitions dans l'es1 arabie saoudite
et aux émirats arabes unis
mais psychologiquement et
stratégiquement il va y avoir des
pourparlers avec les britanniques et les
français et nous espérons encore que les
parlementaires suivront la dernière
initiative de sébastien nadeau qui
demandent l'arrêt des vandam et une
commission d' enquête internationale sur
les ventes d'armes de la france en
direction de ces pays vous en parliez à
l'instant de la france et de la
grande-bretagne un silence de la part de
ces deux grandes puissances ces derniers
temps concernant ce conflit justement
comment on peut interpréter ce silence
des britanniques et des français
alors les britanniques sont dans une
logique de break site de désolation et
c2 également de redimensionnement de
leur politique extérieure puisque
johnson avait une relation très
particulière avec trump donc je pense
que là il ya quelque chose qui va se
faire également en france je pense que
on a un président qui se veut tout
puissant qui est une culture
géopolitique extrêmement faibles qui a
utilisé des symboles pendant très très
longtemps sans avoir rien mis derrière
ces symboles et depuis quelques depuis
deux ans à excuser explose mais risqué -
les termes dans le notamment au sahel en
libye et puis au yémen
alors il ya encore une possibilité bien
sûr c'est que les grandes ong
française qui ne se sont pas tellement
montrer nous rejoignent devant notre
requête au conseil d'état il ya déjà à
l'action des chrétiens contre que pour
l'abolition de la torture et la peine de
mort et la torture
action contre la faim médecins du monde
stop sur les moisséens fois yémen et
sherpa qui sont avec nous et nous avons
un bon espoir que le conseil d'état ait
le courage de dire le droit et le grand
international c'est le traité
international sur le commerce des armes
l'article 6 qui dit que les états doit
cesser immédiatement les transferts
d'armes quand ces armes pourraient être
utilisées à des crimes contre l'humanité
crimes de guerre c'est le cas
aujourd'hui au yémen et benoît tient que
va-t-il advenir de ce conflit si toutes
les grandes puissances justement neuf
ans de vente plus d'armes aux wallabies
saoudite et aux émirats à venir donc
quand on observe de là les conflits dans
le monde et la façon dont ils
s'organisent
il ya deux moments qui permettent cette
désescalade 17 arrêts du conflit et
l'ouverture de la parole à l'ouverture
de négociations une d une d un des
arguments à des paramètres c'est
l'épuisement des combattants
le deuxième paramètre c'est la vente des
armes
on ne peut pas faire la guerre si on n'a
pas les munitions pour faire la guerre
effectivement le matériel est là mais il
faut les missions il faut les airbus
français pour ravitailler les avions de
chasse en vol il faut les munitions que
la vente
la france vend régulièrement pour un
meilleur pour alimenter les canons
caesar pour alimenter les chars leclerc
pour alimenter les
les mirage 2000 qui sont eux qui sont
actuellement en activité au yémen les
ventes d'armes sont c'est pas pour rien
que secrète traité a été fait ce traité
a été fait quand nous l'avons conçu nous
de l'autre côté au bureau ng c'était
pour prévenir ces graves violations des
droits de l'homme ces graves violations
du droit international humanitaire
la seule manière de les prévenir c'est
de cesser ses ventes d'armes et après il
y aura un espace il y aura un espace de
parole et nous espérons qu'elles ont la
voix du peuple yéménite sera un peu plus
audible merci beaucoup aux nombreux
jeunes d'avoir été avec nous cet après
midi sur arte france rappelle que vous
êtes président de l'association action
sécurité éthique républicaine merci
beaucoup